tonight republican congressman jim
censor-brenner
has filed a complaint with the house
ethics committee urging them to quote
immediately open an investigation into
allegations that eric swalwell
was in fact compromised by a chinese spy
yeah that would be important if in fact
he had a relationship and they might
actually have incriminating evidence on
him
why is he on the house intel committee
we continue to follow that story
meanwhile last night's squad member
congresswoman ocasio-cortez takes to
instagram
yeah to cook lemon pasta with salmon for
followers
and then using the platform to respond
to critics that call her radical take a
look
you know shout out to my fellow radicals
who
think that you know we should live in a
humane advanced
society and that we shouldn't be under
the thumb
of a seven dollar minimum wage and
you know racist systems
because i don't know because that just
benefits whoever
the people are in power to already be in
power
so you know shout out to my radicals
now this morning she posted a video on
twitter highlighting
which parts of her first term radical
agenda
she was able to achieve take a look
i authored and introduced the green new
deal with senator ed
markey and secured 115 house and senate
co-sponsors on it
regional versions of the green new deal
were also adopted by 10 local
governments including the state of new
mexico
and cities of austin los angeles new
york city boston and more
we unveiled the green new deal for
public housing which would invest up to
180 billion dollars over 10 years we got
president trump's former lawyer michael
cohen to state on the record
that president trump was engaging in tax
fraud and to name other potential
witnesses on the presidential campaign i
co-chaired the climate unity task force
with secretary kerry
to help shape president-elect biden's
two trillion dollar climate policy
meanwhile yesterday she knocked biden's
agenda saying it quote had
oh it's a little hazy citing a lack of a
cohesive vision
across his uh cabinet here with the
reaction fox news contributors jason
chaffetz and tammy bruce bruce are with
us
well you know looking at the court
decision tonight tammy
and understanding it's likely
ramifications in a lot of ways
uh one has to wonder is america really
ready for what is about
to hit them if this now becomes the law
of the land
well look i think that first of all
calling alexander ocasio-cortez is a
a radical is an insult to actual
radicals
this nation is the radical idea our
constitution
is radical the last radicals we saw were
in
the mid seventeen hundreds our founders
radicalism is coming up with something
completely new
that sets people free she is not a
radical
she is someone who is spewing platitudes
for a failed idea for a failed system
to well effectively trick people
into thinking she represents something
it is an
ignorant point of view you can ask the
people of venezuela
about her kind of radicalism there is
nothing radical
about the failed communist states that
have destroyed people's lives
she has been misled her cohorts have
been misled
and americans want a future they can
count on that is what is in front of the
supreme court right now not that young
woman
cooking some salmon over instagram
spouting platitude